for a startup called cassava and today
we will speak about how we learned that
we use some geospatial data and what
tools we found useful and to find this
data and to store it and to analyze it
so before going deep into that I just
wanted to give you an overview of what
we do what is a cassava and what we do
there as data scientist so cassava is a
start-up based in Milan it's an instant
buyer this means that the main activity
of the company is to buy apartments
renovate them and then resell them so
the advantage for the our customers are
for the persons that want to sell an
apartment the advantage is that we
guarantee that we buy the apartment in
30 days which is a lot less than the
average in Italy so in Italy it takes
between three and six months most of the
time and for the person that buys the
apartment from us the advantages that
they buy a renovated apartment what we
do as data scientist so until now we
mainly worked on on what is called the
valuation platform the valuation
platform is a tool that is running
currently on the website of the company
where our customers can go write
information about their apartment and
after around one second they will get
price that cassava would be willing to
pay for their apartment we built this we
started in June more or less we built it
from scratch I don't want to go into
much detail about the model we used I
can just tell you that it's a machine
learning model based on regression
and gradient boosted trees but on top of
this model we use something that is
called comparable transaction analysis
which basically means that for a target
apartment that we want to get the price
off we look around the apartment on a
radius of I don't know let's say 500
meters and we apply these regression
models on these apartments and then we
do some kind of every Jing and data
analysis but from this I just want you
to get the idea that the location of the
apartment is important because we we
have to find these radius we have to
find the distance from our target
apartment to the apartments that we
already have in the database so a
location is very important for for our
modeling for the valuation so we use
three types of information in order to
build this model first are the
characteristics of the apartment I mean
I this makes sense right so things like
how big is the apartment on which floor
is it located what is the status of the
apartment is it renovated is it not
renovated and so on so for example you
might imagine that an apartment on the
sixth floor on in a building without an
elevator it's gonna cost less than an
apartment on the first floor let's see
another important information is the
area so where is the apartment located
in the city usually in Italy every city
has the area splitted so there is a map
available that you can download with
these areas and the third that we
thought was useful was the distance to
points of interest so things like the
distance from the apartment to the
closest subway station or the closest
park or is there some train passing
right outside your window so these are
all things that could influence the
price so for things like the
characteristics we had this information
from our customers from our internal
database but from the for the other two
types of features we had to find
somewhere else okay just to test you a
little bit I gave you some hints what do
you think are the three most important
rules of real estate one have a guest
good good you guess so yes location
location location so yes I can't mention
before it's important to know the area
of the apartment and what are the points
of interest around and maybe you don't
want to be this guy or maybe what you do
I don't know okay so in more detail when
we started searching how to do this or
how to find this information how to
store it how to use it we saw that every
software we were looking at had this G's
inside the name so like okay this G's
must be important so system and it is a
system designed to capture store
manipulate analyze manage and present
all types of geographical data and there
are different software's that help you
do that so for example Nicola will talk
about pasta cheese which is an extension
of Postgres and that helped us store and
also manipulate the geographical data we
used a bit qgs which helps visualize
geographical data so there are quite a
lot of tools like this ok geospatial
data can be of two types so vectors
which are things like points lines or
polygons and these are this is data that
has exact location and hard boundaries
or raster's which is more like
continuous data without higher hard
boundaries or exact location we will
talk only about vectors today
so vectors can have different formats
one are one of these formats is a
shapefile so you remember I mentioned
before that we need the information
about the area where the apartment is
located I said we downloaded this from
the websites of the city hall of each
city where we operate and this came came
in as shapefiles these are some special
kind of files for storing geographical
data and they are supported by most
software and you will see later how we
how we manage them for the other type of
data that we needed so for the points of
interest we decided to go for Open
Street Map which is basically like
Google Maps but open source and it's
called by some the Wikipedia of maths so
the idea was we needed to download and
save data about these points of interest
so we realized it wouldn't be very
useful to every time we someone asked
for a variation on our website to go and
search for these points of interest like
to call the API and go and search for
this points of interest so we decided
for each city where we operate we need
to download them and store them somehow
the good thing about Open Street Map is
that data is free for anyone to use you
can improve it if you see something is
wrong you can improve it I mean it's
open source and data can be of three
types so there can be nodes or points
these are things like the train station
the subway station power school things
like that
there are ways which could be closed or
open so closed ways are things like a
park or a garden open way are streets or
train platforms and the third type is
relation and relation you can see here
an example
are the zones so the areas of of the
city
okay so amazing we can do this on
OpenStreetMap but how do we actually do
it so there are different tools like
overpass turbo for example where you can
write a query and you run it and you get
what you can see here on the right so
here the query is to find all the parks
in some area and you can see here that
it found them but the problem like I
said is okay it's here but how do we put
it in our how do we start using it how
do we make it you know usable so
actually overpass turbo allows you to
store this data the JSON for example so
you can see here an example of what it
looks like
so it's geometry it's a type of of type
polygon and then you can see the
coordinates like latitude and longitude
for this polygon okay great we are one
step further but now we also need to
store it so the idea would be to store
it in a database that looks something
like this so you know you have okay this
polygon is located in Milan it has this
ID and it represents a park or something
like that and so now Nicola will give
you more detail about how we actually
did this
so that's a story that actually most
Maine simple database or some special
expansions and all those things much
easier way my sequel estan we decided to
dispose this for several reasons
so first image should probably using
possible sequence so position there what
we that think you want to use it and
also I think it's water has one it does
some very specific optimization and
actually were
you want to evaluate the price of the
apartment the first thing you do what it
located and what we do look okay what
are the ten closest apartment to this
apartment so to do that
and we did well we do is like in a
database we have a table which contains
from every line Department for which we
know the price and we know actually the
calling of this apartment so we thought
a coordinate variable in this point
table a point column sorry and thanks to
that we can actually use easily use some
function which is called SD distance in
the positives to calculate all the
distance between all your pattern you
have in your database which can be very
weak and the point that you interested
like the important you want to evaluate
so again this you interview could say
okay I just take latitude longitude I do
some equally in distance nothing so
fancy why do you bother with all of that
but I think is going to be clear maybe
for the second example another thing we
want to know every time we evaluate an
apartment we want to know to which zone
these apartments belong so I think now
you can hardly understand at least so
bit harder just knowing all the
coordinate of the point by yourself
writing your own function to understand
if it's this point it belongs to zone is
really much much harder and here again
you just have to define a column which
is a polygon column okay and that you
can with directly from the origin and
use the intersect function and directly
you can F you and so if your apartment
belongs to
zone or not so it's even better than
that actually using Bush because this
two kind of people in the world actually
there are flatters people and then they
have people with very wheat here we
think that the hearth is actually a
sphere and actually when we want the
calculus time between two points you
should do very fancy did we do a
calamity calculation that actually
nobody wants to do so the good thing is
like positives is actually a candlestick
about that so if you want to keep it
simple and you say okay the earth is
flat I don't care about being very
precise anyway I work on a very local
type and all you have to do is like when
you create your column and project
yourself to declare okay I want this to
be a geometry type so when you do that
calculus but it's gonna be less precise
if you want to go more fancy it's very
easy you just say okay and I'm going to
work with geography type you just
declare it as geography and going to all
the calculation with those crazy 3d
things you know because those wid people
apparently they are right that is going
to do anything for yourself which is
already much much simpler and that's a
third thing for which is even better to
you suppose this this thing is called a
spatial index because you know that in
sequel usually you want to if you want
to be efficient you better put some
index and so many of your cons if you
want to do Jones for example and there's
a similar concept that you can apply in
geospatial database so the main idea yes
like every time you store a polygon for
example in this database
what posse is going to do is going to
draw around those polygons the bounding
boxes so from those complex polygons
sorry so from those complex polygons you
can arrive at simple bounding boxes and
instead of storing sorry instead of
storing a lot information here you can
store just actually for every polygon
get it just for store for floats so it's
much quicker you can index them so it's
going to help you a lot for example if
you want to know okay you ask purchase
is the green polygons intersecting the
the blue one if you start from the line
usually with two should have to do a lot
of complex calculations actually if you
use the spatial index you can already
see the okay since the bonding box are
not touching each other I already know
that those polygons student inserts
intersect and this can change
dramatically the speed of your void
computation so this helps us a lot
okay so now I just talked about this but
actually we are in PI D that conference
so now let's speak about Python so how
do you use this thing if you want to
read it launch it from a Python script
so actually there's several way of doing
that and the way you interact with
produce it's actually symmetric way you
interact with any sequel database in
Python in everything so there are a lot
of way to do it but since we are data
scientist I don't know for you but the
thing you do all the time is to use
pandas sudden tenacity of this which we
call function and very easy way to do it
is you can declare a string which
actually is the sequel call you want to
do and you can give this screen let me
put the function you're going to read
you cannot get your data frame which
physically represents your what is in
your database that's fine actually from
is that actually it's quite simple I
mean I get for data scientist you know
you don't have to bother too much you
know sequel you do this and get your
results maybe you can get a bit trickier
for example if you start you want to
start okay I don't want to query
everything I just want to query some
variables and those variables will
depends on some parameters in my script
somehow so you want to do if something
like okay I want to declare a list of
rebels I want to query and this will
change somewhere in the script and I
really want to be able to in my sequel
query to create only those variables so
you can also still do this creating this
discrete string but then you have to be
a bit smart because you can just put the
list in your string you have to say okay
if to add commas because treating sequel
they use commas like this without square
brackets so it's okay fine with I guess
you can start to see it can start to be
a mess and I did this a lot actually
I mean even did much worse you know
because I saw some where conditions with
some condition depending and I would I
became a crazy ninja about a string
manipulation in Python just do those
crazy sequel thing and then one day when
I T Kollek want
and so my screen name is like oh god
poor guy okay what are you doing to
yourself what are you doing cure so
there's some way to do that a bit
smarter those things maybe may seems
more complex in the beginning but once
those things are set up it's easier so
one possible way to do that is to use
something which is called sequel alchemy
so I don't know if a lot of us are
familiar with sekolah Kimmy okay good so
I didn't know that actually and not so
long ago so it looks a bit strained
because you okay but why do I have to
define this strange table object and to
create this metadata thing that actually
is used as I don't understand what's the
point and in the end okay there's a lot
of a bit of setup to do but once this
thing is done it allows you to do things
much more efficiently because for
example if I take back the example of
before I want it to create just a list
of robots you know you just can just
declare a list of variables and then put
it directly in the sequel crane you
don't have to do any string string many
manipulations you just a stupid example
but when you do other things it can be
quite useful and this is actually a very
big topic I mean I'm not expert at all a
sequel Kimmy I just use it as a data
scientist because I found it very useful
in this in this way so once you seek
well Kimmy actually so since we were
speaking about pauses you have to know
okay how do I do now connect this
process actually it's quite quite
similar because in yen what you have
okay we have possible sequel which is
your database possesses a special
extension of progress so here we are in
the sequel world if you use sequel Kimmy
you can communicate with post graphical
and she won't if you want to use the
community with post this you need dr
Kimmy but you know the digital Kim is
just an extension versus equality me
that allows you to use all those
geospatial extension so if I go back to
the query we were doing before and in
sequel actually actually I could start
to use them
you see sequel Kimmy and you're in the
function of do alchemy so you contingent
that not that much complex more complex
they're quite similar to the other ones
and believe me when you start to do more
complex thing these things come it's
going to help you a lot so it's quite
nice because even though you know this
thing is just a few lines in the entity
when you think about all the calculation
that is done on the on the back and how
old
optimation that was done with all these
special index how to query efficiently
very very very quickly
the closest apartment that you want to
evaluate it first it's very important
because we only want people on the
website not to wait you know two minutes
to get the answer we want the answer to
be minute so this helped us to do this
very actually without knowing anything a
few months ago you just build everything
actually we realize that a lot of tools
already available to help us to do that
so that's what we wanted to say in
ending your special day that can be can
seem a bit complex when you don't know
it can be a bit scary with actually
nowadays you know there are so many
tools that they are to help you that if
you want to do it in in fitting and feel
interested in the field I say just go
for it
thank you
[Applause]
question
I have question I have question
regarding calculate distance calculation
did you manage to use any API to
calculate the distance in let's say
proper way I mean for example how goo
map is doing that or you know for now we
just do the simple equation I mean you
know not so we don't do the road
calculation yes this could be a little
improvement to be done actually and did
you do any search about the tools or
let's say good API so do that or you
didn't start now we still didn't start
the same I have a question because at
the beginning you said that you
basically download the map and then you
use your calculations based on what you
don't know I want to ask to you and how
often do you update those those
databases and do you keep your reference
to the previous point because let's say
Maps to update some time and points do
change how do you approach this okay
actually are they speaking for now since
the very new things we just only did
once for the cities and for now it's
fixed and we for sure we can update it
later but super we still didn't take
another order with a lot of stuff to do
before so for sure we should find a way
to manage this in the future but for now
we don't handle it hello thanks for the
presentation I have a question regarding
the quality of Open Street Map what do
you think about it is it as good as
Google Maps do you find it hard to find
all the places around the spots I don't
actually I was surprised personally I
think it's very good and ok now we walk
on the big high densities or maybe we're
did a bit bias because when I like for
Kevin Malone
yeah the level of detail of the map is
very strong I mean squizz even if you
look at parks you have also the list of
benches the type of benches on which you
can sit so the information is really
crazy it's even actually sometimes
higher quality than Google Maps
those benches still not but maybe in the
future thanks I have a question how big
your database is in general because you
said that you had like a performance
issues but how big was the data set so
it depends so we have this about the
properties and they said is it about all
those polygons and song like the parks
don't we ever exactly have to say for
the polygons but things like a few close
to 1 million polygons I think something
like that and for the properties of few
hundred thousands ok that's it
well you mention about to way of
representing the data GOG geometry and
go graphical and in terms of analysis of
one particular city which one model do
you use so - well now but in the level
of city you can go for geometry because
it's I mean especially city of like
Milano's not like the poverty of the
earth gonna start to influence things so
you can go simple and faster
I would have a question about the
bounding box you show on the to improve
the performance of the calculation you
perform on the database because you
showed the picture of the star and the
bounding box that shows that the star
covers with with one line but in fact
the box are covered but the the figure
and the blue line do not cross how do
you check this interpret these guesses
because it's obviously their defaults
information that these two shapes sorry
I didn't unless you have the star you
have the blue line okay you write the
bounding box as well of then you say
that box are cover one to each other but
they figure they are around do not cross
yes so how would you check this okay so
actually the thing is like the idea of
this is like you okay when you have like
1 million polygons in database actually
most of the polygons are so far from
each other that you don't even want to
consider them thing is like if you
already want to know okay which polygon
in text set intersect at this point if
you can already very quickly say okay we
have ten pound box intersection among
those 1 million then you know okay among
those ten now I'm going to set to do the
real advance calculation so in his way
actually these things you suggest do to
a filter but what you already know that
it's not gonna happen
and once bounding box could potentially
say that okay those two things and
intersecting each other you have to do
still the compute calculation but you
really gain a lot of time by not caring
about the things that you know from the
beginning yet they're not gonna
intersect each other okay thank you
quick question about production izing of
this model so you can you please
elaborate more on how this service work
because you said that it's working love
on your website which allows to do live
searches yep just a little bit more
information about this okay I don't know
how much del you want to know so
basically what we have is some flask app
within Python so that takes the input
you know JSON which is characterizing
the the pattern of its location the
script is actually calling a database is
the medical database to know what other
clauses Department to the page returns
what are the closest Apartments then we
do the machine learning on those ones
and we get the final thing so everything
actually runs on AWS and we lie a lot on
doctor to help us to that's actually
what allowed us to put this in
production very quickly hi so I have a
question about the pauses and whether
it's have some tools for visualization
of data or do you have like do pythons
passionate special actually so there are
several ways to observe actually it is
this dimension is Q this tool actually
from this tool this graphical user
interface you can connect to to post
this and visualize directly but even if
you use DB bruh the Aussie quality data
actually this it's already integrated if
you click on one polygon you can see
directly a little OpenStreetMap with the
polygon that you see that's a lot of the
already very nice integrations for that
thanks question okay thank you
thank you